Alamikum guys. Before the video starts,
brothers and sisters, one Umar is
working in Pakistan with the floods
that's hit the country. 1,700 people
have lost their life. Millions of people
have lost their homes and been
displayed. So the videos that you can
see here, the pictures that you can see,
guys, is demonstrating what one is doing
on the ground. We know Gaza is important
and we know what's going on there. But
brothers and sisters, we cannot enable
and turn a blind eye to the suffering of
Muslims in different countries. Be it
Pakistan, be it Turkey, the earthquakes,
wherever it may be, Afghanistan, so many
other places need our help. And I know
all of us have given as much as we can
to Gaza. But brothers and sisters, wahi,
just imagine your home wrecked.
Thousands of people have died. Your
family members have passed away. You
have nowhere to live. Brothers and
sisters, they need our help as much as
Gaza does. So I urge you guys,
inshallah, it's 100% donation policy.
Donate whatever amount, even if it's£1.
The prophet peace be upon him said, "The
best form of sodak is to give water."
Brothers and sisters, let's give them
food and shelter and water to drink so
they can overcome this tragedy.
Inshallah, I urge you guys to go to the
link and donate now. Enjoy the video
to brothers and sisters and dear
friends. So, um I was away.
Alhamdulillah, my family and I came back
and there was a video that I meaning to
touch upon which is the apology of this
brother. Um, I'm going to watch this in
I'm also going to do some clarification
regarding his friend the green pill
something like that which um I made some
assumptions which I'm going to clarify
inshallah but I'm also going to touch
upon a few other stuff as well. So
here's this video of this brother who
came out and spoke out against manklash.
He seems like a sincere brother. He
seems wellmannered which is very odd for
him to do that action which is very
bizarre but here's his apology video.
Let's see what we can take from in also
let's talk about his friend who promoted
this when it first came out about it
being a joke etc. and he messaged me
saying that he it was a stitch that he
didn't say that
here's a video of the brother's apology
video
>> talking to a lot of people but most
importantly uh people of knowledge and I
consensus they told me Ahmed your
message is we agree with it 100% but the
way that you did it was wrong and it
can't be that the people of knowledge
are wrong and I'm right here it'll be a
ignorance and arrogance for myself if I
was to say that so with that being said
um I'd like to first and foremost
apologize to my family. Second of all,
I'd like to apologize to Da Salafi and
the Salafies um for the scholars and the
students of knowledge that have
sacrificed for this dean and this da for
years and for me to just come out of
ignorance and emotions and and ruin that
that image that they sacrificed for
years. Wallah is selfish. The reason why
I did what I did was out of and out of
seeing my community and seeing uh my
people in ignorance and instead of
tackling tackling it with wisdom and
subhan Allah because of the ignorance
and emotions I probably made matters
worse uh I definitely made matters worse
by ruing the image of I tried to give
the hak to the people by covering it in
filth and subhan allah all uh all that
the people are seeing is the filth
around
I'm not trying to justify myself for my
wrongdoings
and I I seek forgiveness from Allahh
first and foremost and then I seek
forgiveness from for those that I
oppressed those I transgressed against
also like to say I'm looking at the
comments Allah I'm innocent from those
who are backbiting against
Allah saying all sorts of evil things
and saying that he's a career of I am
free from it and that includes um Mu and
his family um in the Grand Mosque. I'd
like to apologize everyone that he had
to deal with the situation at the time
and was left in a difficulty um and
embarrassing situation. I'm embarrassed
of my actions. So I'd like to apologize.
I still have to give them justice and um
and I was and I transgressed. Um so I'd
like to apologize to to them for my
behavior. Um, and I'd really like for
everyone to separate my actions with the
message.
>> So, subhan Allah, I just want to say
subhan Allah, I'll be honest with you, I
see nothing I genuinely see nothing but
sincerity from this pro. I generally
don't see anything but he meant well and
he went about the wrong way and even
though I believe um he said that his
teachers again I don't know I just hope
make dua to Allah that this guy is not
associated to the right right street
measure whatever it's called in
Birmingham
and this espah may Allah protect you bro
if you are I mean I'll be honest with
you I hope you're not because I don't
think you would have done they would
have allowed you to do this apology like
I hope you are with balance
Um Taher White uh Subhan Allah people
like Faruk um you know alhamdulillah we
deem myself to be Salafi as well um so I
just sadly brothers sisters sadly a lot
of them like great greatl and adab this
brother seems like a very levelheaded
good brother who in the moment maybe had
that thing and wall the best of sinners
are those who repent subhan Allah and
we're all sinners subhan allah I hope
you guys enjoy the video guys but before
that please download the salah pro app
brothers and sisters we are a charity
all of our services on the app is for
free. Free kibl finder, no ads, free
salah reminders, encourages you to pray,
tells you salah times. You can book a
salah instructor, a Quran instructor.
You can order a guided prayer map for
absolutely free if you want to learn how
to pray salah. Videos on how to pray
salah, salah hubs, and many, many more
broken sisters. We are not an app that
shares your information with third
parties. All of our services on the app
is for free. Download it now inshallah
and enjoy it, guys. Let's go back to the
video. So may Allah subh forgive you.
But just one thing that aku just said
you know that your teachers told you
that what you said was what you should
have what you said was true but the way
you went about it. I I don't know what
you mean by that.
You said about your community cuz your
community was oppressed. What did Muy
Mang say about your community? I'm
genuinely trying to understand what did
he say cuz you said about tohed
du to Allah. When did Mu say otherwise?
I'm I'm genuinely just like a bit I was
like where did this come from? Because
what has mufti mdan he talks about tohed
he talks about shik he talks about this
stuff you know so what is it that you're
talking about we still do not know but
anyways I believe what you done was
wrong let alone the execution like the
way you done it was wrong because there
was no need for you to do a like is
known for what misconduct are you
talking about bro he's known for what so
anyways brok I will say to you I hope
you are around good brothers who are
genuine salafies and not these extreme
cult members which we have warned
against over and over again you seem
like a good brother you used to be in
the British army Subhan Allah. And I
think the bounce back of what you was
doing etc. And you may have not been
practicing etc. Now you're trying to
overcompensate by going to other extreme
balance. Don't let them suck your im out
of you. Yes. There's certain I'm talking
about this coat. Yes. This espe
you know how many of them that come to
me and apologize to me for slundering
me, backbiting me. Subh you know how
many of them have fall of the dean. Wall
I know three four who have fell off the
deen. And these guys have totally left
and abandoned them. They used chew them
and they kicked them out. So many. So,
subhan all I ask Allah to protect you.
Coming back to your friend of the green
pill who shared the subhan allah the
thing on Instagram. I'll just go to cuz
I was uh trying to talk to him as well
here. Let me see. Uh I just want to see
if the video is still up. Um let's just
see. As far as I know, I don't think the
video is up. I think he's taken it down.
If I'm not mistake, I can't see it on
his post. amlaykum.
>> So he done a video about Yes. So he's
taking that down. He was telling me that
I accused him wrongly uh of being
complicit in the sense where he came and
which I believe he's complicit. But to
say that he orchestrated this and there
were cameramen there etc organized. This
is a false assumption and I ask Allah to
forgive me. Um and because Allah says in
the Quran some assumptions can be a sin.
Some because some can be justified
because at the end you know him well you
vouch for him. This video comes out you
post it. So I have a right to be
suspicious about it because like said we
used to judge from what was what was
that stop now we judge from what's
apparent. for you. Even though I could
have assumed the best in you, but there
was stuff that out there where I could
have say. So I want to make that
clarification that he did not
orchestrate this this green pill.
However, you did it to me in my voice
message with you that you done a stitch
which meaning that it was not you who
wrote that text about oh over a joke but
you still posted. It's like somebody
saying that you are a zani you you you
are someone that sleeps around and I go
I posted it. I didn't write the text.
Why am I sharing the information? I'm
I'm as good as a part of it, bro. In the
Sharia, if somebody accuses one of
slander and another one shares
information, I'll get I'll get flogged
myself. 18 lashes for slander. So, I
want to make that disclaimer. I
apologize for saying that you was
complicit. You orchestrated this. True.
It can be classed as a negative
assumption. Yes. However, you was you
did share that videos. You did share it
and you did make accusation about Mu
being misguided because you went to him
about credit card. Brother, I'm I'm a
public figure. I don't care. You said to
me Medina, brother, we get spies
everywhere, bro. What are you talking
about, bro? There are kufur who go going
to Medina, bro. Subhan Allah. So, you
asking him a question because he said
something generic because he didn't know
who you are. He's a misguided person. On
what basis of knowledge you saying that?
But anyways, I don't want to make that.
I just want to make a disclaimer that
that was an assumption on my side. Good.
Perfect. No problem. I'll make that very
clear. I've got no ego about that. But
just know, bro, you stitch that you
shared, you are complicit in it and you
was wrong for doing that. So, that's all
I was saying. I'm talking about the
other brother, not the brother at the in
the video. And I ask Allah subhanaa tala
to ask Allahh to forgive you. Um and you
seems like a sincere brother akim. May
Allah protect you and bless you and give
you beneficial knowledge and protect you
from these individuals who are going to
consume you and destroy your IM. I ask
Allah to make you around good companion
good companionship. Inshallah if you're
around those who are warning you against
THman
uh myself listen brother may Allah
protect you. You're in the wrong
company. That's all I'm going to say
inshallah. Till next time.